for the first time every Chilean over
the age of 18 will be able to weigh in
on a new road map for their future
like most constitutions Chile's new
draft Charter was born out of upheaval
millions of Chileans disenchanted with
their institutions and Decades of social
inequality launched an unprecedented
social Uprising three years ago
peace was re-established when nearly 80
percent of citizens voted to do away
with what many Saw as the root of all
evil their dictatorship era Constitution
I think the great Merit of the Chilean
process was to have transformed a very
disruptive moment that threatened to
destroy our institutional order and turn
it into a democratic constitutional
solution
the result is a draft Charter which if
approved in today's referendum would
Herald a new political social and
economic era for this country September
4th marks another extremely significant
election in Chilean history and they are
both connected 52 years ago Salvador
Allende was voted in as the world's
first democratically elected Marxist
president only to be overthrown three
years later in a military coup led by
General agusto Pinochet the architect of
Chile's current constitution
the new charger is a major shift from
pinochet's free market model it would
guarantee social rights like Education
Health and pensions and give recognition
and autonomy to indigenous people it's
also the world's first constitution to
guarantee gender parity and respect for
nature it's a constitution that takes
into account climate change and that
gives very strong Provisions for the
protection of of the environment it's
it's very oriented to sustainable
development I think that's very a
Cutting Edge aspect of the of the text
but there are many who believe that
left-wing delegates who drafted it went
too far and imposed a text that doesn't
reflect the concerns of the political
Center and conservatives
constitutions cannot be left or right
they have to represent the people's
interests regardless of ideology
that's why those who will vote against
the Constitution are demanding the
process start all over again it's like
baking a cake
if the cake comes out flat and it's
burnt you don't try to fix it or you can
try but it will never be a good cake so
just throw it away
even supporters agree that the new
charger must be improved suggesting that
whatever the outcome Chile's
constitutional process isn't over yet
to see a Newman Al Jazeera Santiago